mesdames messieurs
c'est d'avoir conscience qu est la seule
évocation de cette conférence de presse
dédiée aux qu'ovide nombre d'entre vous
ont pu ressentir un sentiment de
lassitude de jour sans fin ont pu se
replonger dans les périodes difficiles
que nous avons vécu collectivement
depuis près de deux ans
oui le virus circule à nouveau il
circule vite une circule partout en
france et dans le monde à l'évidence ce
virus répond à des cycles émaillée de
périodes de flambées épidémiques et de
périodes d'accalmie
oui la france connaît à son tour une
cinquième vague oui cette cinquième
vague sera sans conteste plus forte plus
longue que la quatrième vague est
survenu cet été si le variant en cause
le variant delta très contagieux est le
même les conditions climatiques
automnale et hivernale favorise sa
diffusion d'autant que nous passons
davantage de temps à l'intérieur qu'à
l'extérieur
le professeur jérôme salomon va dans
quelques secondes vous donner tous les
éléments pour comprendre où nous en
sommes mais avant je veux vous dire
qu'il n'ya aucune fatalité face à ce qu
vide et à ces cycles depuis deux ans la
donne a changé et nous avons les moyens
de nous prémunir individuellement et
collectivement des conséquences
dramatiques
des premières vagues je vais vous dire
que nous avons encore notre destin entre
nos mains
grâce à l'une des couvertures vaccinales
les plus fortes au monde grâce aux
gestes barrières grâce au pass sanitaire
ainsi et suite au conseil de défense et
de sécurité nationale qui s'est tenue
hier je ne vous annoncerai ni
confinement ni couvre feu ni fermeture
anticipée des commerces ni limitation
des déplacements à l'heure où nombre de
nos voisins européens font face
à la vague la plus violente depuis le
début de la pandémie et sont contraints
de prendre de telles mesures
restrictives nous faisons le choix de
concilier liberté et responsabilité et
nous considérons aujourd'hui que nous
pouvons encore passer cette vague sans
recourir aux outils les plus
contraignants si nous savons utiliser
pleinement les cartes que nous avons en
main je vous présenterai dans quelques
minutes les décisions qui ont été prises
par le président de la république pour
protéger les français puis le ministre
de l'éducation nationale abordera la
question des écoles mais avant tout
professeur salomon je vous laisse la
parole
l'europe confrontée à une importante
cinquième vague de qu'ovide est re
devenu l'épicentre de la pandémie les
conditions hivernales
température humidité vent pollution avec
davantage d'activités et de
rassemblement en intérieur la baisse du
respect des mesures barrières le port du
masque l'aération régulière des locaux
le lavage des mains ne pas se faire la
bise se serrer la main et l'insuffisante
couverture vaccinale contribuer à cette
tendance internationale préoccupante le
vaccin est une arme très efficace pour
réduire le risque de formes graves ou de
décès mais son efficacité notamment
contre la transmission de la maladie
diminue avec le temps d'où l'importance
du rappel
les pays situés à l'est et au nord de
l'europe ont été les premiers touchés
faisant face depuis début octobre à une
flambée des contaminations
l'autriche a été contrainte de confiner
sa population la belgique les pays bas
le danemark le royaume uni ou encore
l'allemagne dont le taux d'incidence
vient de dépasser 400 sont sévèrement
touchés et connaissent des situations de
tension dans les hôpitaux les pays
d'europe méridionale largement vacciner
comme l'espagne le portugal et l'italie
jusqu'ici épargnée par cette nouvelle
vague connaissent également une remontée
rapide des cas ces derniers jours toute
l'europe est à présent concernés par
cette cinquième vague
le taux d'incidence sur sept jours--
dépasse deux cent soixante-dix pour cent
mille habitants alors qu'il est de 48 et
demi au niveau mondial l'europe
représente aujourd'hui 67 % des
nouvelles contaminations recensés dans
le monde
cette vague touche désormais toute la
france métropolitaine de façon homogène
avec une incidence en forte hausse le
taux d'incidence s'élève à 193 et le r
effectifs la vitesse de propagation de
l'épidémie est de 1,6 ce qui se traduit
par un doublement du nombre de personnes
touchées tous les 11 jours la barre des
trente six mille nouveaux cas en 24
heures a été dépassé dès ce lundi elle
correspond au pic observé en août lors
de la quatrième vague
les nouvelles hospitalisations et
admission en soins critiques toujours
décalé de une à deux semaines par
rapport aux cas sont aussi en nette
augmentation au niveau national
8765 malades de lakovic sont
hospitalisées dont 1483 en soins
critiques la transmission du virus
s'accélère l'impact sanitaire de cette
vague est réel les personnes aujourd'hui
hospitalisés sont essentiellement non
vaccinés âgées et/ou particulièrement
fragile immunodéprimés notamment selon
les projections réalisées par l'institut
pasteur le pic de la quatrième vague de
patients atteints de colite graves
hospitalisés en soins critiques pourrait
être atteint dès début décembre donc la
semaine prochaine en france
métropolitaine
l'impact sanitaire est réelle mais
nettement réduit grâce à la couverture
vaccinale importante et à l'efficacité
du vaccin et du rappel sur le risque de
décès de formes graves et
d'hospitalisations
il ya en effet près de huit fois plus
d'entrées en soins critiques parmi des
personnes âgées de 20 ans ou plus non
vaccinés que parmi celles complètement
vaccinés le vaccin protège donc
fortement contre les formes graves avec
un risque / 8 risque encore diminué
après rappel depuis de nombreux mois
nous avons fait collectivement et
individuellement
de gros efforts qui nous l'avons vu ces
dernières semaines ont permis à notre
pays de retarder l'arrivée de cette
cinquième vague par rapport à nos
voisins
l'instauration et le contrôle bah
sanitaire notre taux de vaccination
parmi les plus élevés en europe
88% des douze ans et plus sont vaccinés
neuf adultes sur dix font partie de ces
efforts a souligné nous devons garder ce
bénéfice de la mobilisation en faveur de
la vaccination
reprenons aussi des réflexes de
prévention les gestes barrière cruciaux
tels que le port du masque en
particulier à l'intérieur l'aération
régulière des locaux le lavage fréquent
des mains ne pas se faire la bise ou se
serrer la main adoptons à nouveau nos
bons comportements de la stratégie
tester alerte et protégée au moindre
doute au moindre symptôme ou si je suis
qu'à contacter je me fais tester même si
je suis vacciné si je suis positif même
vacciné je m'isole immédiatement et je
préviens mes contacts c'est l'addition
de toutes ces mesures vaccination pas
sanitaire mesures barrières tester
isolement qui nous permettra de freiner
la diffusion du virus est de nous
protéger collectivement le virus va
continuer à circuler activement cours
des prochaines semaines car nous le
savons les conditions métérologiques et
nos activités principalement en
intérieur font de l'hiver la saison
idéale pour la propagation de tous les
virus notamment à transmission
respiratoires pour passer les fêtes de
fin d'année avec nos proches dans les
meilleures conditions mobilisons nous
individuellement et collectivement
mobilisons nous pour protéger au mieux
ceux qui nous sont chers mobilisons nous
pour protéger nos professionnels de
santé sur le front de la pandémie depuis
près de deux ans est toujours là pour
nous soigner gérer l'importante activité
de l'hiver et les épidémies de covin
bronchiolite grippe et gastro entérite
merci beaucoup à jérôme salomon alors
certains s'interrogent
comment une vague est elle possible
alors que 90% d'entre nous âgé de 12 ans
et plus sommes vaccinés est-ce que ça
signifierait que le vaccin serait
finalement moins efficace que prévu non
en fait il faut bien que vous compreniez
que si nous n'avions pas cette
couverture vaccinale importante nous
serions déjà foudroyé submergés par la
vague épidémique parce que le variant
delta est extrêmement contagieux
beaucoup plus que le commis de 19 du
début et quelle évidence nous serions à
cette heure-ci déjà probablement même
tous confinés puisque des mots des faits
et des preuves
la part de français en réanimation selon
qu'ils soient vaccinées ou non vacciner
jérôme c'est le monde a dit parle
d'elle-même c'est un fait dans les
patients admis à l'hôpital pour qu'ovide
la part des patients vaccinés est dix
fois moins fréquentes que celles des non
vaccinés une réduction par dix imaginez
donc le nombre de malades en réanimation
avec la vague épidémique mais la
quatrième deux cet été si nous n'avions
pas une couverture vaccinale optimale
par ailleurs nous savons avec l'exemple
allemand qu'il existe une corrélation
très nette entre la couverture vaccinale
dans un territoire et l'intensité de
circulation du virus dans ce territoire
plus les régions allemandes eux sont
vaccinées moins il ya de cas et moins il
ya de cas graves et moelleux sont
vaccinés ce qui est des grandes
différences en allemagne d'une région à
une autre plus il y a deux cas graves et
de la même manière d'ailleurs en france
on est capable d'objectiver à l'échelle
de bassin de vie dans des territoires
que là où la vaccination est plus faible
parce qu'il ya une tradition vaccinale
moins forte par exemple eh bien c'est là
qu'on enregistre les taux d'incidence
est le nombre de cas graves le plus
important donc ça veut dire que le
vaccin nous protège il ne faut pas il ne
faut plus en douter si vous aviez encore
des doutes là dessus il nous protège
individuellement en réduisant très
fortement le risque de développer une
forme grave et d'être hospitalisé ils
nous protègent collectivement parce
qu'il est réduit la circulation du virus
il ne l'anéantît pas la circulation il a
réduit très fortement et donc ça va lui
aussi le risque de contaminer autour de
nous des personnes qui serait fragile et
qui pourrait développer des formes
graves ça veut dire que même si je suis
jeune je me vaccine pour protéger moi
même mais aussi pour protéger toutes les
personnes que je peux rencontrer au
quotidien et qui elles ne sont peut-être
pas suffisamment trop g le vaccin est
donc très protecteur mais il est vrai
aussi que son efficacité va diminuer
avec le temps ce qui est un phénomène
classique avec les vaccins en effet un
vaccin apprend à votre système
immunitaire à votre corps à fabriquer
des armes contre le virus qu'on appelle
des anticorps qui fait que si le virus
se présente vous êtes déjà armé vous
savez fabriquer ses armes contre le
virus et voulait empêcher de vous
infecter mais avec un petit peu au bout
d'un certain temps l'efficacité du
vaccin elle diminue votre mémoire
immunitaire et n'est pas infaillible et
donc il ya un premier appel qui est fait
pour dire au système immunitaire
souviens toi comment est ce que tu
fabriques ces anticorps contre le virus
est bien ce que nous savons c'est que
dans le cadre des virus des vaccins
contre le coc vide au bout de quelques
mois il faut renouveler ce rappel pour
réactiver la mémoire immunitaire et
alors on va avoir une démultiplication
de l'efficacité de l'immunité et ce dès
les premières heures qui suivent le
rappel de vaccination c'est très
impressionnant de voir cela l'immunité
baisse on est moins protégé au bout de
quelques mois et d'un seul coup avec le
rappel immunité redevient absolument
optimale du coup les scientifiques en
france comme à l'étranger considèrent
désormais que ce rappel il est utile
chez tous les adultes chez tout le monde
dès 18 ans parce que l'immunité même
chez les adultes jeunes elle commence à
décliner au bout de quelques mois et
dans le contexte de forte circulation du
virus que nous connaissons les autorités
scientifiques considèrent aussi que ce
rappel il faut pas attendre six mois
pour le faire il vaut mieux le faire des
cinq mois après la dernière injection ou
après avoir été infectés d'ailleurs la
haute autorité de santé que j'avais
saisi sur la question vient à l'instant
de publier des recommandations qui sont
celles que je vous indique et qui sont
donc la première annonce que je vous
fais ce matin que je confirme c'est que
désormais le rappel vaccinal sera ouvert
à tous les adultes âgés donc de 18 ans
et plus des cinq mois après leur
dernière injection ce qui veut dire qu
en pratique cela concerne 25 millions de
français 25 millions de français dont 6
millions ont déjà reçu leur appel il
reste donc 10 9 millions de français à
date qui deviennent éligibles pour le
rappel de vaccination et que nous
invitons donc à se faire vacciner dans
les deux prochains mois
certains d'entre vous s'interrogent si
j'ai été affecté par le cos vide est-ce
que je dois comme une ferme on rappelle
la règle est simple retenez-le à bien
une infection correspond à une injection
pourquoi parce que si vous avez été
affectés de la même manière votre
système immunitaire apprend à fabriquer
des anticorps des armes contre le virus
et donc une infection peut donner une
protection équivalente à celle procurée
par le vaccin ce qui veut dire que si
vous avez été infectés vous avez eu une
dose et que vous êtes à cinq mois de la
dose de la dernière injection recevez un
rappel si vous avez reçu une première
injection qui ensuite vous avez une
qu'ovide cinq mois après vous recevez
votre rappel si vous avez eu deux
injections et que vous avez eu malgré
tout le coc vide dans cinq mois vous
pourrez bénéficier d'un rappel c'est une
règle qui est clair qui est simple et
qui s'appliquent à tous les adultes âgés
de 18 ans et plus en parallèle nous
voulons continuer d'aller chercher
d'aller vraiment mobiliser les quelques
six millions d'entre nous qui ne sont
toujours pas vaccinées alors qu'ils sont
éligibles depuis bientôt un an quelles
que soient les craintes quelles que
soient les réticences il n'est plus
temps d'attendre ni un vaccin français
pour certains ni d'avoir suffisamment de
recul on est bientôt un an de la
campagne vaccinale des milliards de
terriens ont été vaccinées vous savez
que ce vaccin est efficace vous savez qu
il vous protège vous et celles et ceux
qui vous entourent on va continuer de
mobiliser tout ce qu'on peut pour aller
vous motiver à recevoir ce vaccin on va
développer à nouveau des opérations avec
des médiateurs sanitaires à destination
des personnes fragiles et isolées en
lien avec les collectivités
territoriales
on va re développer des barnums de
vaccination notamment dans les centres
commerciaux parce que ça fonctionne bien
on j'appelle à nouveau et je sensibilise
à nouveau mais je sais qu'ils le font au
quotidien les médecins les pharmaciens
et les infirmiers à les motiver leurs
patients réfractaires pour qu'il puisse
se faire vacciner et solennellement
j'appelle celles et ceux d'entre vous
notamment les plus âgés et les plus
fragiles qui hésitiez encore à franchir
le pas parce que ce virus tue et que ce
vaccin vous protège
l'autre question qui peut se poser c'est
ce que nous avons suffisamment de
vaccins pour vacciner ses 19 millions de
français eh bien oui nous avons
suffisamment de vaccins plus de 25
millions de vaccins arn messagers sont
actuellement stockés dans les
établissements de santé mais également
de chez les médecins et les pharmacies
en ville des os des doses de pfizer et
vidéo the modern a là aussi je rassure
tout le monde à partir de 30 ans on peut
recevoir un rappel avec du moderna qui
est un vaccin extrêmement efficace ces
rappels peuvent se faire donc auprès de
tous les professionnels de santé
habilités à vacciner en ville les
médecins dont 15000 pharmacie du
territoire les sages femmes les
infirmiers les masseurs
kinésithérapeutes les laboratoires de
biologie
ces professionnels de ville ils peuvent
commander désormais autant de vaccins
qu'ils le souhaitent et ce depuis
plusieurs semaines et on estime qu'
environ 4 millions de doses de vaccins
arn messager qui sont actuellement en
stock chez vos professionnels de santé
en ville si vous le souhaitez vous
pouvez aussi opter pour les centres de
vaccination il reste plus de 1100
centres ouverts sur tout le territoire
national la france reste l'un des pays
les mieux mailler en centres de
vaccination et avec les élus locaux avec
eux nous avons concerté ce matin même
avec le premier ministre avec les ars
avec les traits fait nous allons ouvrir
rouvrir ou amplifier les centres de
vaccination existants et ce dès ce
week-end car la vaccination en rappel
pour les adultes est ouverte à compter
de ce samedi et vous pouvez d'ores et
déjà vous rendre sur les plates formes
de prise de rendez vous en ligne pour
réserver vos créneau vous comment nous
le savons tous le monde évidemment les
19 millions de français appelés à se
faire vacciner ne pourront pas être
vaccinés aujourd'hui ou demain ça va
prendre un petit peu de temps et c'est
tout à fait normal et ce n'est pas grave
c'est d'ailleurs la traduction de votre
mobilisation mais je vous le redis il y
aura des vaccins pour tout le monde tout
le monde pourra être vaccinés dans les
délais vacciner revacciner des millions
et des millions de français en quelques
semaines c'est certes une promesse une
prouesse logistique mais c'est une
prouesse que nous avons déjà réalisé ce
printemps et cet été grâce à
l'extraordinaire mobilisation de nos
professionnels de santé désagrège des
préfets des élus locaux des agents des
collectivités territoriales que je
remercie à nouveau pour leur très grande
mobilisation et ce à compter de ce
week-end qui sera à nouveau renforcée
une autre question autour de la
vaccination ça concerne la vaccination
des 5 11 en vaccination des enfants
l'agencé européenne du médicament
communiquera aux alentours de 15 ou 16
heures en disant qu'elle considère
manifestement j'attends l'avis définitif
que la vaccination peut être ouverte
dans des conditions de sécurité pour les
enfants âgés de 5 à 11 ans quelles sont
désormais les étapes à suivre en france
d'abord je saisis le conseil consultatif
national d'éthique parce qu'il ya des
questions éthiques qu'il se pose en
termes de protection collective de
protection individuelle s'agissant des
enfants ensuite je saisis bien sûr la
haute autorité de santé pour qu'elle
puisse regarder décrypter en toute
transparence l'ensemble des données à
disposition et déterminer dans quel
cadre dans quel contexte pourrait ou non
être ouverte la vaccination aux enfants
de 5 à 11 ans dans tous les cas cette
vaccination si elle était décidée en
france ne commencerait pas avant le
début de l'année 2022 puisqu'il faut
pour cela recevoir les vaccins avec des
dilutions de vaccins adaptés aux enfants
les règles concernant le pass sanitaires
vont quant à elles et en cohérence
évolué vous le savez à compter du 15
décembre le pass annie terre pour les
plus de 65 ans ne sera plus actif si le
rappelle n'a pas été fait dans un délai
de sept mois après l'infection ou après
la dernière injection
et à compter du 15 janvier se passe
sanitaires de tous les autres publics
c'est à dire les français âgés de 18 à
64 ans ne sera plus actif si le rappelle
n'a pas été fait dans ce délai qui reste
inchangé de sept mois après la dernière
injection de sorte qu'une fois que vous
êtes à cinq mois de votre dernière
injection vous aurez deux mois pour
recevoir votre rappel et ainsi conserver
le bénéfice de votre pass sanitaires par
ailleurs et à compter de lundi 29
novembre lundi prochain les tests pcr et
antigénique qui donne accès au passé ni
terre pour celles et ceux qui parmi vous
n'êtes pas encore vaccinés aujourd'hui
sont valables 72 heures avant ils
étaient valables 48 heures quand le
virus circule et un peu plus compte tenu
du fait que le virus circule beaucoup
plus aujourd'hui nous dit nous réduisons
à 24 heures la durée de validité de ces
tests pour bénéficier du pass sanitaire
ce qui veut dire que très concrètement
si vous n'êtes pas encore vaccinés et si
vous souhaitez bénéficier du pass
sanitaires vous devrez donc vous faire
tester tous les jours à vos frais sauf
si vous êtes symptomatique avec une
ordonnance de votre médecin sauf si vous
êtes reconnu qu'à contacter par l'
agence régionale de santé ou par
l'assurance maladie
la vaccination est notre meilleure arme
notre meilleure protection le passé ni
terre est une arme supplémentaire qui
est efficace et qu'il est montré dans
toutes les études mais nous devons
pousser notre avantage face au co vide
jusqu'au bout ce n'est pas la seule arme
dont nous disposons je veux parler des
gestes barrières du masque et de
l'aération des mesures simples qu'il
appartient à chacun d'entre nous de
respecter au quotidien et dans la durée
et pour lesquels un relâchement
compréhensible que le virus circule et
moins est constatée nous devons donc
collectivement nous ressaisir et nous
avons je le répète notre destin en main
chacun est responsable de la santé du
groupe et nous sommes tous en première
ligne dans le combat contre le virus
être libre ce n'est pas refusé mordicus
ces mesures qui évite de saturer les
services de réanimation et qui
permettent de retrouver une vie aussi
normale que possible ces petites
contraintes du quotidien sont les clés
de notre liberté être libre c'est
d'abord être responsable essai mesuré la
portée de nos choix nos services de
réanimation accueille des centaines de
patients qui étaient libres de passeurs
vacciner des patients d'ailleurs parfois
jeunes qui ont préféré la croyance à la
science qui ont préféré la conviction à
la responsabilité sont ils libres
aujourd'hui je ne le crois pas il est
dommage de mettre sa vie en danger pour
une idée fausse de manière générale et
c'est pour cela que je vous parle de
responsabilité je sais aussi que les
gestes barrière peuvent vous paraître
parfois dérisoires par rapport à un
virus auxquels nous faisons face depuis
près de deux ans mais ils sont d outil
inestimable dans le fait de frais la
propagation du go vide et la ste covin
ne s'arrête pas de circuler parce que
c'est l'heure d'un moment de
convivialité à l'issue d'une longue
réunion autour d'un verre hélas de
retour des poignées de mains ne transmet
pas que de la chaleur humaine il peut
transmettre aussi le virus il faut donc
rester vigilant à tout instant reprendre
les bonnes habitudes qui ont parfois été
perdu le gel hydroalcoolique lui aussi
doit faire son retour partout on
constate qu'il est pas il a parfois
disparu de certains endroits nous ne
manquons clairement pas de gel donc il
nous faut en consommer un maximum
le masque lui aussi a été
progressivement haute et notamment entre
des personnes vaccinées qui se disent
bondois été vacciné je suis vacciné on
risque rien on enlève le masque c'est de
ce retrait s'est opéré progressivement
par usure ou par fausse réassurance des
normes est contenue la circulation du
virus il faut leur mettre d'ailleurs à
ce titre est à compter de demain un
décret rendra à nouveau obligatoire le
port du masque partout en intérieur dans
les lieux couverts par un pass à
lithaire donc même en cas de passer ni
terre dans un lieu recevant du public
vous devrez porter le masque les préfets
seront aussi habilités département par
département à rendre obligatoire le port
du masque en extérieur pour des
événements en extérieur tels que par
exemple on peut l'imaginer dans les
prochaines semaines les marchés de noël
ou encore des brocantes s'agissant
d'ailleurs des marchés de noël leur
accès sera lui aussi désormais soumis
aux passes sanitaires
je disais parmi les autres mesures
barrières et à l'aération est une mesure
qui est essentielle elle permet
d'évacuer les particules de virus en
suspension dans l'air on doit tous
adoptés ou réadopté ce réflexe d'aérer
souvent partout par exemple si vous avez
une réunion qui dure une heure vous
prenez la peine d'ouvrir une fenêtre
même s'il fait un peu froid sédition
vous ouvrez dix minutes la fenêtre et ça
permet l'évacuation des particules
virales et ça réduit le risque de
contamination par ailleurs partout où
c'est nécessaire il peut être utile
d'installer des capteurs de co2 ça ne
permet pas à l'aération mais ça permet
de vous alerter quand il est devenu
urgent d'aérer les autres gestes
barrières sont tout autant utile on les
rappelle jérôme simplement tousser ou
éternuer dans son coude
lisez un mouchoir à usage unique bref
vaccination parce sanitaire
gestes-barrières nous avons d'ores et
déjà les armes pour combattre cette
nouvelle vague mais dans les prochaines
semaines nous disposerons d'une arme
supplémentaire
depuis le début de l'épidémie les
laboratoires du monde entier cherchent
des traitements qui sont efficaces
contre le coc vide la recherche a là
aussi réalisé des progrès considérables
et je tiens je tiens à le dire la france
est à chaque fois à la pointe pour être
l'un des premiers pays au monde à en
faire bénéficier les malades depuis
quelques mois nous disposons ainsi d'un
traitement qu'on a à base d'anticorps
dirigés contre le virus un traitement
injectable qui nécessitent d'être
hospitalisée et qui permet de diminuer
les risques de développer des formes
graves chez des personnes
particulièrement à risque plus de 7000
français ont reçu ce type de traitement
mais la donne va changer puisque à
partir du début du mois de décembre nous
avons l'arrivée d'un nouveau médicament
cette fois ci c'est un médicament
antiviral il s'appelle le môle du pire à
vire et nous fondons beaucoup d'espoir
dans ce traitement c'est un médicament
qui étant comprimé qui pourraient être
prescrits par la médecine de ville par
vos médecins généralistes qui sera
disponible dans les pharmacies
d'officine en ville c'est un médicament
qui sera réservé aux personnes qui sont
à risque de faire des formes graves ou
par leur âge plus de 65 ans ou parce
qu'ils ont des maladies chroniques il
vaut médecins recevront toutes les
indications et les règles de
prescription de ce médicament et pour
les gens qui sont concernés dont qui
sont à risque de formes graves et qui
présentent des symptômes en formes
symptomatiques de co lead ce médicament
s'il est administré dans les cinq
premiers jours les études cliniques
montrent qu'il peut réduire par deux le
risque d'être hospitalisé je tiens à le
dire là aussi la france sera le premier
pays européen en faire bénéficier ses
citoyens d'autres traitements vont
arriver dans les prochains mois à base
ou d'anticorps ou d'anti viraux qui
viendront renforcer notre arsenal contre
le coc vide mesdames messieurs nous
sommes prêts nous ne sommes pas désarmés
nous ne sommes pas démunis nous avons
des outils pour la combattre cette
cinquième vague les gestes barrière les
rations à tous les étages les vaccins
les tests et désormais c'est un immense
espoir les traitements si nous parvenons
à mobiliser tous ses outils si nous
agissons en liberté et en responsabilité
nous pouvons réussir à franchir cette
vague sans davantage de mesures de
contrainte pour la population c'est
notre voeu le plus cher je sais qu'il
est partagé par celles et ceux qui nous
écoutent et nous regardent aujourd'hui
donc soyons mobilisés soyons solidaires
soyons courageux une fois de plus nous
l'avons été par le passé nous le serons
encore dans les prochains jours et les
prochaines semaines je vous remercie et
je passe la parole à mon collègue jean
michel blanc qu'est ce qui peut vous
parler de la question particulière des
écoles
[Musique]
bien mesdames messieurs l'évolution de
l'épidémie dont nous parlons depuis tout
à l'heure concerne évidemment l'école
comme le reste de la société et comme
nous l'avons fait depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire nous allons donc ajuster
notre protocole pour tenir compte de
cette réalité notre objectif notre
boussole vous le savez bien reste la
priorité d'une école ouverte c'est ce
que nous avons fait tout au long de
l'année dernière c'est ce que font
désormais d'ailleurs tous les pays
européens et donc toutes les mesures
dont je parlerai ensuite sont guidés par
cet objectif mais tout d'abord je
voudrais faire un point sur l'état de la
situation sanitaire dans l'espace
scolaire nous avons aujourd'hui en
france pour les plus de 12 ans les 12 17
ans un taux de vaccination élevé c'est
l'une des meilleures couvertures
vaccinales en europe pour cette classe
d'âge derrière la péninsule ibérique
nous avons ainsi 77% de primo vacciner
et 75% avec un schéma vaccinal complet
pour rappel la moyenne de la couverture
vaccinale en europe ses 55% c'est
évidemment un atout pour l'enseignement
secondaire où ces élèves sont vaccinés
je voulais je voudrais signaler aussi
que la vaccination des professeurs
atteint 90% dans la dernière enquête que
nous avons fait ce qui est largement
supérieur à la moyenne nationale et donc
merci là aussi aux professeurs pour leur
civisme et leur sens des responsabilités
bien sûr les campagnes vaccinales
continueront et ces chiffres peuvent
encore augmenter à ce jour donc la
situation et est en croissance et hier
ont dénombré 8 1500 classes fermées ce
chiffre était de 4100 le 19 novembre je
rappelle que au pic de la crise l'an
dernier nous avions jusqu'à 12000
classes fermées cela donc restent
inférieurs à certains pics que nous
avons connus mais c'est une tendance en
hausse et donc nous sommes attentifs ces
fermetures de classes concerne
exclusivement quasi-exclusivement
l'école primaire je voudrais rappeler le
dispositif que nous avons mis en place
dans l'espace scolaire depuis la rentrée
de septembre avec évidemment une grande
différence entre l'école primaire et
l'enseignement secondaire pour l'année
2000 21 2022 nous avons établi en lien
avec les autorités sanitaires un
protocole graduée comportant quatre
niveaux et le passage d'un niveau à
l'autre dépend de différents facteurs
notamment le taux d'incidence de
dépistage la couverture vaccinale
l'attention des structures hospitalières
et d'autres critères encore le protocole
sanitaire qui s'applique en métropole
actuellement est de niveau 2 et il
comprend des mesures dont certaines sont
bien connus et recoupent ceux que nous
venons d'entendre population générale je
pense en particulier aux mesures
renforcées d'aération ce qui vient
d'être dit sur les salles vaut
évidemment pour les salles de classe
c'est à dire l'ouverture des fenêtres le
plus fréquemment possible et notamment
une fois par heure le lavage des mains
le port du masque obligatoire pour tous
les personnels ainsi que pour les élèves
dès le cours préparatoire
la limitation du brassage par niveau la
désinfection des surfaces les plus
touchées et en mesures diverses et
l'absence de sport de contact et des
distanciation adapter ce protocole donc
continuer à s'appliquer et il est
complété par un protocole de traçage qui
vise à identifier les cas de kovy
déclaré et les cas contacts rappelons
que l'an dernier avant le déploiement
des vaccins c'était notre principal
levier notre la fameuse stratégie tester
alerté protéger et c'est ce qui nous a
permis de maintenir pour l'essentiel
l'école ouverte selon ce protocole un
cadre que vit dans une classe à l'école
primaire entraîne aujourd'hui la
fermeture d'une classe est au collège et
au lycée les élèves justifiant d'une
vaccination complète pour suivre leurs
cours en présence et les contacts à
risque sans vaccination passe à
l'enseignement à distance pour une durée
de sept jours
aujourd'hui donc au collège et au lycée
la cinquième vague à moins d'impact
grâce notamment à la vaccination et
grâce au protocole mis en place et donc
c'est sûr l'école primaire que je vais
maintenant insisté puisque
l'enseignement secondaire avec le
protocole actuel peut tout à fait
traverser la cinquième vague aujourd'hui
pour l'école primaire de nombreuses
familles sont concernées par les
fermetures qui existe nous estimons que
c'est environ 180 mille familles qui
sont concernées aujourd'hui par des
fermetures de classes et vous savez je
suis très conscient et très attentif à
cette réalité
hier nous avions trois mille deux cents
élèves qui étaient déclarés positifs
sont donc des chiffres qui sont assez
importants c'est pourquoi depuis
plusieurs semaines nous avons lancé une
expérimentation dans dix départements
depuis le début du mois d'octobre
exactement pour tester un dispositif
plus adapté et qui nous avait été
inspiré par les autorités sanitaires et
scientifiques lorsqu'un élève est testé
positif tous les élèves de la classe
sont testés à leur tour et donc seuls
les camarades restés positifs restent à
la maison
ce dispositif montre sa pertinence nous
en aurons les résultats complets avec
santé publique france le 3 décembre mais
déjà nous pouvons en tirer quelques
leçons dès lors que nous sommes capables
de l'adapter aux réalités concrètes que
nous constatons car on retire deux
enseignements d'abord il apparaît
important et pertinent de le mettre en
place pour les élèves de l'école
primaire parce que ça permet de limiter
l'impact en termes de fermeture de
classe et ça permet de maintenir le même
niveau de protection des élèves mais on
doit adapter les modalités de dépistage
parce que selon les départements nous
avons constaté des réalités différentes
notamment capacité de réactivité des
laboratoires et des différentes
structures concernées par parcelle ce
dispositif est donc le dispositif
nouveau que nous allons mettre en place
à partir de la semaine prochaine nous en
avons parlé ce matin même encore avec
les collectivités locales les
représentants des collectivités locales
au travers de leurs associations d'élus
que je remercie de même nous en avons
parlé ce matin avec les organisations
représentatives de l'éducation nationale
et les organisations de parents d'élèves
ce dispositif est donc conçu pour
assurer à la fois la protection de nos
élèves et de nos concitoyens et en même
temps une ouverture aussi grande que
possible de nos écoles primaires il n'y
aura donc plus de fermeture systématique
de classes dès le premier cadre vide en
primaire mais un dépistage systématique
de toute la classe
autrement dit seuls les élèves
présentant un test négatif pourront
revenir en classe ces tests pourront
être réalisés par les responsables
légaux et donc nous c'est une mesure de
souplesse c'est à dire que le test peut
être réalisée soit par les responsables
légaux en général les parents au travers
des pharmacies des laboratoires de
l'ensemble des structures qui réalise
les tests soit au travers d'une présence
des laboratoires dans l'établissement
scolaire dans l'école primaire c'est ce
que ceux qui se précisera il se
réalisera tout au long de la semaine
prochaine cette mesure entrera en
vigueur dans le courant de la semaine
prochaine de manière différenciée selon
les lieux puisque la mobilisation des
des structures adaptées est différente
selon les lieux et bien entendu aussi
bien les communes que les directeurs et
directrices d'école au travers des
recteurs seront informés des modalités
je rappelle que le test est gratuit il
est gratuit pour tous les mineurs et que
évidemment tous les mineurs seront mis
en situation de pouvoir être testé le
protocole de niveau 2 est donc maintenue
sur tout le territoire il s'applique
aussi à l'école primaire avec cette
évolution du protocole de traçage ces
nouvelles mesures nous permettent
d'ajuster notre dispositif pour faire
face à l'évolution de la situation
épidémique nous devons rester évidemment
particulièrement vigilant dans les
prochains jours cela vise à limiter le
nombre de fermetures de classes à
l'école primaire on sait que c'est
préjudiciable aux élèves sur la visée
aussi à responsabiliser tout le monde de
façon à ce qu'il y ait finalement plus
de tests réalisés pour les enfants dans
notre pays je sais que nous pouvons
compter sur la responsabilité de chacun
ça a été réalisée dans le passé au
travers d'autres mesures qui
remonteraient ce sens des
responsabilités des acteurs de
l'éducation c'est grâce à la
mobilisation de l'ensemble des membres
de la communauté éducative les chefs
d'établissements les directeurs et
directrices d'école les professeurs les
personnels les parents les élèves eux
mêmes dont on doit rappeler qu'ils font
preuve de beaucoup de civisme dans cette
période que les gestes barrières sont
plus particulièrement respectée dans
l'enceinte scolaire que dans le reste de
la société que nous pouvons donc être un
des pays au monde pouvant continuer à
voir au maximum ces écoles ouvertes et
donc au nom de l'intérêt des enfants je
veux remercier toutes et tous pour la
mobilisation que tout cela va requérir
je vous remercie merci beaucoup jamais
sable en terre et on va prendre des
questions si vous en avez aimé des noms
qui se lève je ne suis pas surpris
mais si les ministres là ma question
s'adresse à olivier ferrand pourquoi ne
pas assumer que ce pass sanitaire est un
pass vaccinale qui ne dit pas son nom et
combien de temps allons-nous devoir
vivre encore sous passé l'été à la
mesure était censé être temporaire enfin
est-ce que grâce à ces durcissements que
vous annoncer aujourd'hui vous pouvez
dire aux français qu'ils ne sauront niro
confiné ni sous couvre-feu à noël alors
que nombre de nos voisins européens vous
l'avez rappelé en sont déjà arrivés là
d'abord je le redis c'est important nous
avons encore notre destin entre nos
mains nous considérons et d'ailleurs les
modélisations qui sont faites par
l'institut pasteur montrent que le
rappel vaccinal l'effet booster sur la
vaccination à la protection collective
et individuelle très rapide un jeu rudin
dès les premières heures dans les 48
heures on retrouve un niveau de
protection optimale contre contre
l'infection quand on a reçu son rappel
peut nous permettre de passer une vague
épidémique intense sans avoir de
saturation des hôpitaux samedi on a
encore notre destin en main
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que le choix
qui est fait c'est lui la responsabilité
et de la liberté est pas celui des
mesures de contraintes telles que vous
avez raison de souligner l ont pu être
mises en place en autriche qui est en
confinement généralisée en allemagne qui
détermine la fermeture de certains
établissements recevant du public ou
encore d'autres pays près de nous qu'ils
mettent en place des mesures type couvre
feu donc vraiment nous nous estimons que
nous avons 7 e cette voie de passage à
travers cette cinquième vague comme nous
l'avons fait lors de la quatrième vague
où il n'y a pas eu de mesures de
contrainte collective de mesures qui
reposerait sur les personnes vaccinées
sur les personnes non vaccinées sur le
passé ni terre fait partie de pour
certains effectivement d'une mesure de
contrainte je peux le comprendre quand
on n'est pas vacciné qu'il soit
contraignant de devoir se faire tester
pour accéder à un établissement recevant
du public mais je le dis c'est encore
plus contraignants pour les français qui
sont 90% à avoir été vacciné équivaut à
nouveau le virus circule et est à
nouveau des soins qui pourrait être
déprogrammée ou des hôpitaux qui
pourrait revoir arriver des malades par
dizaines ou par centaines donc je le
redis le choix de la responsabilité
c'est le choix de la vaccination
néanmoins la différence fondamentale
entre le pass sanitaire le pass
vaccinale c'est qu'il ya toujours la
possibilité vous quelqu'un qui n'est pas
vacciné de se faire tester certes assez
frais pour pouvoir accéder à un
événement un établissement recevant du
public ou rentrer dans un bar ou dans un
restaurant
cette différence allait elle est de
taille pour un grand nombre de français
mais je souhaite que nous n'ayons pu lui
poser la question et nous nous poserons
encore moins la question du pass
sanitaire dans la durée lorsque tout le
monde aura été vaccinés et qu'un signe
nous verrons peut-être des épidémies des
vagues épidémiques j'ai dit que comme
idée était cyclique il y aura peut-être
d'autres vagues dans le futur parent
probablement et que nous pourrons
affronter ces vagues beaucoup plus
sereinement parce que nous serons tous
protégés
bonjour marie chanterait pour tf1 lci ma
question s'adresse à vous monsieur
monsieur verront une question sur la
dose de rappel et l'ouverture donc aux
plus de 18 ans l ouverture de massif de
nouveaux créneaux vous l'avez évoqué
mais à l'heure où vous parlez la plate
forme par exemple d'octo libé d'ores et
déjà encombré beaucoup s'inquiètent de
ces prises de rendez vous alors quand
ces nouveaux créneaux vont-ils ouvrir un
combien de centres vont rouvrir
également est ce qu'on pourra parler de
l'ouverture de nouveaux vaccinodromes
comme il avait été le cas il ya quelques
mois merci d'abord je le redis nous
étions montés à 1600 centres de
vaccination et la ville participaient
pas encore beaucoup à la campagne
vaccinale parce qu'ils étaient ils
étaient limités en termes de commandes
de vaccins aujourd'hui reste 1100
centres donc ça veut dire qu'un maillage
territorial qui est très bon je les dis
nous allons renforcer partout où c'est
nécessaire les centres créés des
nouvelles lignes de vaccination là où
elles ont été supprimées éventuellement
rouvrir d'autres centres là où ils
avaient été fermées et où ça fait sens
mais nous appuyons aussi massivement
vers un transfert vers la ville vers vos
pharmaciens et 115 me les médecins et
sur des milliers d'émigrés les jets
étaient tous cités tout à l'heure les
professionnels de santé libéraux lisez
cette semaine la semaine dernière ils
ont commandé un million et demi de
vaccins sur une semaine du 20 heures la
semaine dernière il avait commandé 1,2
millions de vaccins ils ont au moins 4
millions de vaccins disponibles donc les
français peuvent déjà s'adresser à leur
médecin à leur pharmacien dans
infirmiers sages-femmes l'heure qu'il
est ils peuvent aussi prendre
rendez-vous dans les centres je les dis
nous allons armes et les centres de la
bonne manière pour pouvoir répondre à
toute la demande et je redis un point
qui est fondamental qui n'est pas la
même situation qu'il ya un an c'est que
nous avons en stock à l'heure à l'heure
à laquelle je vous parle suffisamment de
vaccins pour vacciner tout le monde et
que il y à une période de deux mois qui
s'ouvre qui va permettre à chacun d'être
vaccinés qui veut dire qu'on a fait des
projections en montant à trois millions
et demi 4 millions de vaccinations par
semaine nous retrouvons des rythmes de
vaccination analogues à ceux que nous
avons connus au printemps et à l'été
c'est très bien face pas très bien mais
n'est pas très étonnant que le les sites
de réservation en ligne soit saturé à
l'heure à laquelle je confirme la non de
l'ouverture du rappel vaccinal parce que
figurez vous que je reçois beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus de messages et de courrier
depuis des jours et des semaines de la
part de français qui avaient moins de 50
ans et qui voulait être protégé en
recevant une dose rade une dose de
rappel que de courrier de la part de
gens qui ne veulent pas être vaccinés ou
qui ne veulent pas dupe hassani terre la
majorité c'est 90% des français qui sont
vaccinés les intentions de rappels de
vaccination par exemple est d'opinion
que nous faisons montre que la quasi
totalité de celles et ceux qui ont eu
déjà deux doses et tout et tout à fait
prête à recevoir une troisième d'où
d'ailleurs très spontanément les
personnes âgées de 65 ans et plus qui
étaient invités à recevoir rappel les
trois quarts d'entre elles avaient déjà
fait leur rappelle dans le mois qui
suivent est donc encore une fois pas de
stress pas de panique si le site sature
ça va être rétablie dans les prochaines
minutes où les prochaines heures on a vu
ça à chaque fois qu avec des annonces
comme celle ci ce qui veut dire qu'il ya
une appétence des français vous avez
deux mois et pendant les deux mois qui
vont arriver chacun pourra avoir été
vaccinée en bonne et due forme
prabonnaud france télévisions j'aurai
deux questions pour vous monsieur blanc
caire
d'abord est-ce que vous envisagez des
tests systématiques dans les écoles on
se souvient des modèles de l'équipe de
vitoria colza qui montrait que c'était
efficace pour limiter les contaminations
et la deuxième est ce que vous envisagez
impasse sanitaires pour les enseignants
et une petite précision pour vous
monsieur vers ans est-ce que les masques
sont obligatoires ou autre vie enfin
seront obligatoires dans toutes les
salles de sport et les boîtes de nuit
bien merci pour ces deux questions sur
le sur la première vous faites référence
à l'étude de même que lisa s'est en
effet l'étude de référence pour ce que
nous sommes en train de faire et ça a
été l'étude de référence pour
l'expérimentation dont je viens de
parler 7 donc je livrerai les détails
dans comme je vous le disais le 3
décembre à la suite de santé publique
france mais d'ores et déjà ce que l'on
peut dire c'est que l'expérimentation
dans dix départements et très
instructive à la fois par les forces et
par les limites que cela montre les
forces parce que en effet ça permet
d'éviter de fermer des classes mais les
limites parce que parfois c'est
n'arrivons pas enfin nous collectivement
n'arrivons pas à ce que l'ensemble des
acteurs nécessaires soient présents dans
les 24 heures pour faire les tests à
tous les enfants donc cela permet
d'avoir des conclusions opérationnelles
et pour être à la fois souple et
pragmatique ce que nous en déduisons
c'est que oui nous allons finalement
suivre les principes qui était promené
par le professeur colza mais nous le
faisons avec deux modalités finalement
une modalité que nous connaissons déjà
et que nous pratiquons c'est-à-dire un
laboratoire qui vient et qui permet de
tester tous les enfants ou une autre
modalité conséquent la première modalité
n'est pas possible c'est à dire demander
aux parents en ville de faire de faire
tester les enfants et donc l'enfant peut
revenir avec un test négatif ça nous
permet d'étendre les vertus de cette
expérimentation à toute la france tout
en étant pragmatique sur sur la manière
de le faire mais entendu nous allons
continuer à être volontariste sur notre
capacité à déployer des tests avec en
partenariat avec les laboratoires dans
dans les écoles mais jusqu'à présent on
a parfois rencontrées aussi des limites
par exemple dans le volontariat des
parents même pour des tests salivaires
donc là nous pensons que ce volontariat
va être plus grand à partir du moment où
s'il enfin tester ça permet de revenir
en classe
ce qui était évidemment quelque chose
d'important pour tous donc ça c'est pour
votre première question et puis votre
votre deuxième question c'est donc sur
le
passe à lithaire dont vous nous avons
dit depuis le début que le que l'école
était un lieu particulier un sanctuaire
où par définition
chacun venait de manière ouverte même si
évidemment cela supposait le civisme de
tous c'est pourquoi j'ai souligné tout à
l'heure le taux de vaccination des
professeurs qui reste important sur le
moins de 10 % qui restent je les appelle
évidemment à se vacciner et au fait que
nous continuerons des campagnes de
vaccination dans le cadre scolaire ou à
côté du des établissements scolaires de
manière à ce que les adultes qui sont
pas seulement les professeurs d'ailleurs
c'est l'ensemble des personnels
travaillant dans les établissements
et les élèves ne puissent continuer à
être vaccinés chaque fois que nécessaire
sur la question qui m'était destinée sur
les masques et je le dis le décret
demain rendra obligatoire le port du
masque dans tous les lieux fermés y
compris les lieux qui sont soumis au
passé à lithaire les conditions
pratiques précise établissement par
établissement seront précisées dans les
heures qui vont suivre il ya une
concertation avec l'ensemble des
secteurs si pour compléter la question
la réponse à des questions que des fêtes
tout à l'heure sur les prises de rendez
vous il y aura aussi une nouvelle option
qui va apparaître sur l'application tout
senti qu vide qui va vous alerter
lorsque votre pass sanitaire arrivent
bientôt à expiration donc ça veut dire
que vous aurez vous recevrez une alerte
votre page va changer de couleur lorsque
vous présenterez votre pas salutaire
pour vous que vous soyez bien au courant
que vous avez il vous reste tant de
jours où tant de semaines pour être un
jour de votre vaccination pour garder le
bénéfice du patient terre et il ya eu
près de 400000 prise de rendez vous sur
les sites de plateforme en ligne pour
des rappels de vaccination la simple
évocation de la conférence de presse a
boosté les prises de rendez vous donc on
s'attend évidemment est ce qu'il ya un
afflux important aujourd'hui je leur dis
aux français qui nous regardaient et
nous écoute vous allez pouvoir prendre
un rendez-vous dans les prochaines
heures il y aura pas de difficultés
les ministres tardif pour pour ses news
une petite précision technique sur le
pass sanitaires à partir de quelle heure
le patient terre et il valide pour les
personnes qui ont effectué un test
négatif à partir de l'heure du
prélèvement pour partir de l'heure du
résultat concernant la campagne de
vaccination pour les 5-11 ans on vient
de voir que l'agencé européenne du
médicament a autorisé l'utilisation du
vaccin files heures est ce que vous vous
apprêtez comme ce fut le cas les mois
dernier monsieur blanc caire à organiser
potentiellement une campagne de
vaccination dans les écoles primaires et
une dernière question vous concernant
vous monsieur le ministre des
solidarités de la corde sentait
allez-vous des données sur les personnes
vaccinées à nouveau affecté ce qu'il y a
des différences entre les vaccins
est ce qu'il ya des vaccins qui sont
plus protecteur que d'autres et ça vous
avez des autres protections contre les
formes graves qui sont supérieurs à 90
95 % et le rappel vaccinal booste encore
plus les choses a préféré jouer à plus
ou moins 1 ou 2% tous les vaccins qui
sont disponibles les vaccins arn
messager qui sont disponibles pour le
rappel de vaccination sont aussi
efficaces l'un que l'autre c'est
important de le rappeler parce que on
voit qu'un peu de désamour pour le
moderna suite à l' alerte qui avait été
fait sur certains cas très rare de
primes cardiaque chez des gens très
jeunes dans les conditions dans
lesquelles il peut être prescrit et en
plus à demi-dose désormais il n'y a pas
de sujet donc les deux vaccins sont
équivalents je le dis parce que c'est
important vous m'avez posé la question
de la validité du test dans le passât ni
terre c'est à partir de l'heure du
prélèvement
sepa 4 à partir de prélèvements et ça
peut être un test anti génique un test
pcr et c'est à partir de l'heure du
prélèvement sur la vaccination des
enfants on en est pas encore vraiment
vraiment à organiser une campagne
scolaire fesci ça en présence de mon
collègue jean michel blanquer je le
redis d'abord le conseil consultatif
national d'éthique
la haute autorité de santé ensuite
livraison des vaccins destinés aux
enfants qui sont et dilution
particulière on n'utilise pas les même
vaccin que pour les adultes ensuite si
la décision était prise dans d'ouvrir la
vaccination aux 5 11 ans dans quelles
circonstances dans quelles conditions et
ensuite à l'eau si la logistique suivra
je le redis c'est pas avant le début de
l'année 2022
un point supplémentaire sur sur ce sujet
on comprime ans et c'est pour que ce
soient parfaitement claires ce qui est
envisagé c'est que ce soit facultatif
les pays qui le font comme par exemple
les états unis le font de façon
facultative on sait qu'ils ont des
facteurs de comorbidité
supérieur au nôtre enfin touchant plus
de population d'enfants que senna est
notre cas mais en tout est donc
évidemment il y aura des recommandations
particulières pour les enfants qui en
ont particulièrement besoin mais toutes
les perspectives que nous avons ne sont
qu' à titre facultatif c'est important
de le dire parce que c'est ce 6 notre
notre perspective donc y aura peut-être
un vaccin n'est des 5 12 ans pourrait
parfaitement clair dans la suite de tous
qui a expliqué olivier ferrand si ça
devait arriver ce serait facultatif
oui bonjour gabriel gourevitch pour l'
agence france-presse question sur les
tests et notamment sur la capacité des
laboratoires des pharmacies à faire face
à l'afflux prévisible que vous vous
annoncerons déclenché d'une part parce
que la durée de validité des tests est
réduite de 60 12 à 24 heures donc les
personnes qui en ont besoin ils vont ils
aller trois fois plus est par ailleurs
monsieur blanc caire parce que on a vu
que dans les écoles l'objectif que vous
aviez vous même affiché de 5000 test est
très loin d'être atteint vous renvoyez
en partie la responsabilité sur les sur
les parents d'aller faire tester leurs
enfants dans les pharmacies ou les
laboratoires qui donc vont probablement
faire face à un afflux d'adultes est ce
que c'est un monsieur près de créer un
engorgement et de créer une
impossibilité pour les classes de
rouvrir
sur la première partie de la question
nous avons fait réaliser
2 3 millions de tests cette semaine donc
on voit que ça remonte parce que le
virus circule plus mais laboratoire les
pharmaciens l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé qui font des
tests sont capables d'absorber je les
remercie pour leur mobilisation on est
montés à des niveaux plus élevés en
termes de tests je suis pas sûr qu'on a
un très fort impact sur la demande liée
au raccourcissement de la durée de
validité du test dans le passe de 72 à
24 mais si il y avait une augmentation
nous nous suivrons évidemment la demande
en revanche je le redis le meilleur
moyen de ne pas se poser la question
c'est se faire vacciner c'est ce n'est
plus compréhensible c'est plus
compréhensive d'ailleurs vous avez des
régions françaises je regardais la
région bretagne c'est près de 96% des
habitants vaccinable qui sont vaccinées
dont il ya des disparités territoriales
d'une région à une autre il faut
vraiment arriver à monter encore notre
niveau de couverture vaccinale vous
savez si la cinquième vague et démarre
plus tard chez nous et chez elle est
beaucoup plus faible à cette heure-ci
que je suis la plupart de nos voisins
c'est parce qu'on a une couverture
vaccinale qui est beaucoup plus
importante comparer la france et
l'allemagne il ya plus de 10 points
d'écart de vaccination entre les deux
pays donc il est vraiment fondamental de
ce rex mais quand c'est pas encore fait
et d'ailleurs ce point vaut aussi pour
le taux d'ouverture des écoles est ce
qu'on peut constater dans les différents
pays sur ce que vous avez dit sur les
campagnes de tests dans les écoles c'est
vrai que nous proposons nous sommes en
capacité d'en proposer six cent mille
par semaine depuis maintenant la rentrée
et que c'est plutôt autour de 200 milles
qui sont faits avec un certain nombre de
limites qui sont dit qu'ils sont
diverses l'une d'entre elles s'est un
peu je le disais tout à l'heure
l'acceptation dépend donc la nouvelle
formule
premièrement va certainement augmenter
cette acceptation des parents
premièrement deuxièmement et dans la
suite de ce que j'ai amené olivier vers
on ne peut pas engorger le système
puisque je vous ai dit par exemple qui
avait 180 mille familles touchées
aujourd'hui par le phénomène des classes
fermées ça veut pas dire 180 mille
familles dont l'enfant est positif mais
180 milles qui aurait eu
au cours des huit derniers joueurs à
entrer dans cette système là et vous
voyez bien que c'est un chiffre assez
bas par rapport à la capacité générale
du système à tester chaque semaine
merci à toutes et à tous
et très bonne journée